this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thank you very much for the
great introduction I want to put Joy's
swords and surprises sausage put the
human side to it because there we all
know a lot of you is starting your
careers and you have a lot of sorrows
you have lots of surprises but is a
joyful journey to go through so please
we find it and we find it it's all
worthwhile and there's being very
interesting and intriguing to work with
peanuts we starting working with Peter I
working in Bravo which is the Brazilian
cooperation that was for agriculture
development and working with peanuts
when we started 15 years ago there was
very little known about peanuts wilds
very little there's a lot of connections
but not much known about it there was
sick a grand total of six microsatellite
markers for peanuts and the mere act of
extracting DNA was a stumbling block and
until we found a very nice protocol
which is Doyle and oil so in a way new
Jekyll before we knew him personally so
being here giving a same they're invited
by him by V Doyle and now it's is a
great great pleasure and honor so thank
you very much Jeff so what I wanted to
do was in a while I think peanut is not
very well known in a number of places
although we us is very important the
u.s. so I really wanted to give a sort
of good background on what peanuts is
like what the wild species are like a
wild work with wild species and some of
the interesting fine as we've had in the
last couple of years right at the end so
starting with peanut I think most of you
I think the good international community
here but for the American ones you know
United States is a very big producer of
peanut and also very big a user you know
a lot of you have had these in your
school years peanut butter jelly
sandwich
if you're more from the South you may be
familiar with it which is great wall
peanuts love them so it's a very
important crop in the US although us
only produces 6% a lot of the production
is here in China in India most of it
stays there a lot of it is used for oil
or just eaten or for crop for cattle but
Africa is one of our passions is is a
place where it is really port in terms
of staple food is where Anna women are
more involved in the production they
actually the women and the children plan
the peanut a lot of the time they
harvest it and is a source of income for
the families where a society's more or
less male-dominated either sort of a
little bit of freedom and that the women
have and they I'd like to show these
plumpy nut to sometimes use it was
created originally by a French
pediatrician and I love that because
that's our like in a packet food that is
used for combating mal nourishment for
children so there has been some
campaigns and you know have children
would be on hope and they they get a lot
of working up using plumpy nut or
related products so it's something is
really important in Africa and brings
your security in Kenya in a small
supermarket get more peanut products and
I've ever seen anywhere else in the
world I think is just amazing the way
they use it and it so important in
Africa and I think the first written
record that that I've seen there no we
looked at was by gonzalo Nanda severe de
valdes his he was a spanish writer he
wrote chronicles in the times of the
great navigations and then these was
found in de espanol as they
in caribbean's so you know think about
the context of the time the 1500s so
money which is spinach is very common
with the Indians with the native Indians
Christians they can live a comfort in
them and people they eaten most of my
lowly men and boys slaves and by people
who do not pardon the taste for anything
so it really wasn't very appreciated
like it is nowadays but it's interesting
the way he saves the weights eaten by
the native people what 200 years late it
was and it was called iraqis hypogaea
because of the way the fruit bear is in
the end of soil by Linnaeus and it
became very popular in the US by George
Washington Carver he was a scientist
inventor and he thought out 300 years of
peanut and is actually quite famous and
what his work a lot of what we have
nowadays and peanuts in the u.s. is
derived from from his work election if
you can hear me at the back can you hear
that louder thank you thank you just say
if you can't hear
so a rocket hypogaea it's um it belongs
to the family of the papilla need a
subfamily popular needy and it's quite
basil it's here with the stellas aunties
the things the genus that is more
closely related to Arrakis and is the
important feature of iraqis is the
subterranean fruit so the flower the
ovary the peg of the flower is Paula
nized the the peg grows into the soil
and at the end of the peg the fruit is
develops so this because it's a self
pollinating the fruit is under the soil
the dispersion is very poor so you have
in areas you have populations that stay
there for hundreds of years so per year
you have this person of about one meter
so imagined to go one killing me to take
a thousand years so the dispersion is
very poor and a lot of the dispersion of
Iraqis has been done by by native people
so the center of diversity unlike a lot
of people think so you think a pinner to
think Africa because a lot of it made
all its way to Africa in pre-columbian
times but the primer Center zactly in
South America these region the north of
Argentina's south of Bolivia and then
these lines are migration lines you can
see anthropology's is the field work for
apologies because these are migration
lines of the native amer Indians the
first archaeological remains of
something looking like a peanut were
found in Peru about 8,000 years ago and
these are very interesting civilization
the mochi again in Peru they are very
interesting pottery they they were very
well developed
civilization and they if you google
mochi pottery it's very very interesting
so it's worthwhile and among the lots of
interesting pottery some of them look
like peanuts and showing importance of
peanut in their society but more than
that I think it's really nice recently
they found remains of the Lord of Sipan
they were very rich they traded in gold
they had very sophisticated clothes
ornaments and they had very interesting
well probably religious traditions so
Lord of Sipan was one of the most
important persons and look at his
necklace all made of gold and so thus i
once I was gold the other was silver
that shows the Sun and the moon so all
into the peanut so it's it's been very
important in South America for hundreds
maybe thousands of years and if you
being used by native Brazilian India's
visas Kaiba Indians and the reservation
of shingle and they grow simply looking
like a land race and these peanuts here
they do not fit into any of the six
botanical varieties are completely
different so you know is being fought
now that is area is one of the new when
they won all of the new centers of
diversity so that's being established
now
so the origin is here the north of
argentina and south of Bolivia right at
the verge over the Andes and one thing
that is remarkable about about it is
that and for many years researchers
looked what were the progenitors of
peanut and you well established now that
Iraq is appliances and Iraq is door
announces are the two most likely
projectors and Iraqis are announced is
there are several accessions in this
area this is the air of occurrence but
Iraqis appliances has only been found
once and after going back there they
never population anymore so it's
probably extinct in the wild so in fact
we were very lucky to be able to have it
and this is one of the joys of working
with peanuts we know what the
progenitors are and the closest related
species to Iraqis appliance which is
Arrakis magna it's found here about 500
kilometers away lower down so it is very
clear that there was the work of man in
the creation well in the origin of
peanut because they were probably this
week will probably grow in these these
accessions these plants in small gardens
and there was some colonization and
anyway i'm going to show this in a
minute so peanut is an olive tetraploid
so when i started thinking about
genetics you know that's that's what it
is and we have we had some stumbling
blocks along the way because of that but
anyway the most likely progenitor is
iraqis door lenses which is a deployed
is called a genome because you know they
have there is a small chromosome which
is called a chromosome in this central
medic bands and the Iraqis appliances at
some point they crossed there was his
diploid hybrid which was
info tile through spontaneous
replication there was a tetraploid
ization and created something arose that
it's similar to what we know peanut
nowadays but obviously through
domestication and we're very interested
in what made the people at the time
realize that this plant was tetraploid
and was more interesting and it could
actually give rise to something which is
so different from the wild deployed so
as you can imagine since peanut is a
tetraploid and the wild species are
deployed that created a tremendous
bottleneck so we cannot find you cannot
cross them when you cross them you get
some info tile triploids which are
useless so in nature you have these
deployed species which are already quite
separate and then you have the peanut
which is tetraploid so it's completely
isolated from its wild relative so gene
flow is irrelevant is very limited this
very old slide very very old slides re
from maybe 10 years ago showing
microsatellite markers in different one
market in different accessions and
different extra batanga varieties and we
found very very little polymorphism
that's always been a problem for peanut
very little polymorphism and accessions
of the same species in wild we find all
sorts of polymorphisms so we one of our
missions and our roles in what we do is
to bring wild alleles to bring new
traits to general Chu help of genetics
and peanuts and to increase resistances
this was a in an old photo again ten
years ago of the first synthetic a
little ploy to produce via group so you
have the synthetic here and this was a
spontaneous and of fungus the fungus
sometimes the green house you have virus
and fungal have all sorts so peanut got
completely fried
completely devastated with the fungus
and the synthetic was still happy alive
so that was because we knew about
resistances but this is sore subject
came in spontaneously in the greenhouse
and we kept this for posterity so this
is where the wild species are
distributed in South America so we can
see a lot of river flow through river
areas here and we see also when it
looked more closely a lot of migration
groups now I'd like to point out these
one here these is a as an isolated patch
of Arrakis tell experiment which is one
of the most resistant plants species of
peanut and we don't see you can see that
is clearly taken by Indians and we find
this isolated population here and we
find all the populations around other
parts of Brazil so in there are many
evidences of people carrying peanut
seeds or Arrakis seeds in south america
in the racket is found in all sorts of
environments so involved with all in all
sorts of conditions and there has been
having a lot of effort for collection
for understanding what the plants are
like or and identification and these are
the three people who are alive I mean a
lot of them I disease now but these are
the three most important people who work
with peanuts who understand about wild
species daughter child seems some from
Texas A&M Hill Emma Seydoux from
Argentina angels Devils who I'm a
colleague with in rapper Brazil there
are several banks germplasm banks all
over the place but these are the most
important ones and I would like to point
out that Tim until the convention of
biodiversity exchange on plasma exchange
was much easier so
here in the USDA in America I think
there are about seventy percent of the
species which has been identified so at
the time when people could go to Brazil
to Argentina to South America to collect
they live apart there and bring some
today we're CA and also transferred to
other places what other banks after the
conventions this all became very
difficult to know to exchange in Brazil
and in Argentina national laws stop
researchers from sending native
materials abroad and make it actually
quite difficult to work it's quite
difficult to work with native materials
each was that has a amazing bank of
cultivated species of accession he has
the mandate to keep and to distribute he
has again some issues which are beyond
the scope of these of this talk so it's
very difficult to get material for my
cruiser to but the usta I mean we've
been having a lot of pleasure working
with the usta because they they have a
very well organized Bankers Trust parent
everything's online and it's very easy
to to get so if you make a request to
the USDA you get a little packet of 20
seeds and they're very very well
organized in obliging so you know it's
it's a very good bank and weird and it's
going to be very important to keep it
and we've been trying to work with the
usta and convince funders and everything
that it's important you keep it there
and the work we're doing producing new
tetraploid our our objective is to have
it all deposited in the USDA the work we
do here in the US so that is available
to the peanut community worldwide
so as expected while species have all
sorts of resistance to pests and
diseases so these are the main pests and
diseases of peanuts that somebody was
asking me today lately spot root-knot
nematode rust alpha toxin viruses etc so
for all of these some species have been
found to be resistant and in our work
and this is work from starting some
years back we found that Erica's nagano
which is a beer genomes vicious was
extremely resistant to rust well
actually this is not a ruckus magnet
this is peanut but this is just showing
what the Ross is like and Iraq extent of
sperm is very very resistant to nematode
amongst other things peanut not having a
very good either genetics to work with
not be polymorphic enough and not being
very resistant at all so let's work with
diploid to bring in resistances so how
can we understand where the resistances
are so remembering that peanut has a and
B genomes so we decided to tease out the
two genomes of peanut by using two
different deployed populations so across
a rocket appliances which is the
progenitor of peanut with the bee genome
species Iraqis do Renee's the progenitor
of the eight a part of sub genome with
the a janome species with an agostino
former and in parallel we created
populations for the a and for the beep
of these sides created maps phenotype
for not only visible for all sorts of
other traits identify cutie else created
markers for resistance link two
resistances and we can use these markers
now to do Marcus's selection with peanut
but obviously these plants are not very
useful because they are in the diploid
stage so what we do in parallel to it
creating the building bridges creating
plants which are actually compatible and
have harbor they are the resistances so
what we do is we cross a wild species
from a genome with the wild regional
species and artificially duplicate the
genome we use colchicine there are all
sorts of things you can use and the
synthetic plant now is now compatible
with peanut so we can use it directly
with process they are theoretically
stable not quite like that but they
supposed to be quite stable and we can
use them freely this is what all the
species which are theoretically
crossable with peanut once tetraploid
eyes these Iraqis appliances which falls
into the Iraqis hypogaea be genome clade
Iraq is the remains as it falls into the
auriga's hypogaea agent on clade these
are introns for different genomes the
genome size so these ones with the sign
are the ones that we have used in
crosses and we have obtained
successfully tetraploid sweet ride other
combinations but not everything is
possible there Dupri's I gotta get all
sorts of incompatibilities which we have
never studied very much but we know they
exist so we try to select the ones that
are closer to the to the beach to the
genome of hypogaea but we have been able
to get crosses from other more distant
species so we've done crosses in Brazil
we've then crosses here UGA we are in
collaboration with tiptoeing in
collaboration with Senegal and we've
created a number of plants which are
compatible with peanut and we are doing
back crosses here in the US in Brazil
and also in Senegal
these are the place where wild species
are being used in breeding programs the
ones in yellow are the ones we are
collaborating with and I'd like to go
into some specifics some aspects which
are very we find very interesting very
surprising very interesting to look at
when we duplicate the plants when we get
these two while together what happens to
them what happens in the genome what
happens what does the plant look like so
a lot of you here very familiar with
with all this concept of Nicola typic
facts of genomic merger etc so it's not
going to be surprising from a lot of you
but for us was fascinating so we get a
species which has a small leaf cross
with another one or you get duplicate
and you get a big leaf much more similar
to the tetraploid one and that doesn't
happen only once it happens in all the
crosses we look at the cell size in the
leaf so this is the guard cells here of
the deployed and look at the guard cells
on the tetraploid they're much larger
epidermal cells as well when we look at
photosynthetic pigments again so the
yellow ones are the diploid green ones
are the synthetic tetraploid and blue is
peanut so what you can see is that once
we tetraploid eyes the diploid we get a
much greater level production of
photosynthetic pigments
and then what would be the effect on
drought because of course we've been
involved a number of projects that
involve drought and okay so let's look
at the wild they a lot of them are grown
in very dry environments so we could try
and find our lives from the wilds right
wrong so we find it is not quite like
that because and then I'll show you why
so when we look at drought how can you
compare the drought of a plant which is
a peanut which is a bushy plant which
has an architecture which is very
particular and compared with a plant
which is craggy which has less branches
less leaves and you know how do you
compare you compare yields do you
compare growth jookin so we had to tease
it out a bit and find some traits which
would be common to peanut and to the
wild and one of them was the
transpiration rate so we did this work
in collaboration with Vincent videz as a
colleague from his friendship works a
tree cruiser to India he's doing a lot
of wonderful work with drought so we
looked at the transpiration rate on the
stress so this is one is 100 when you
the plant is in a pot one hundred
percent of water which is in field
capacity and these is zero water so the
fraction of trust parable soil water is
measured and this is the measurement of
the stress in the plant so this is the
normalized transpiration so you have
this stage in which you stop you stop
watering the plant of all your water it
in in amounts that you know that the
soil is getting dry gradually and ease
observe the transpiration of the plant
compared to controls so what you think
really is the matter conductance how
this tomato is closing and how the plant
is reacting to the drought and these is
called a threshold in which the plant
stops really slows down transpiration
and risk
wants to be the drought imposed and well
the late to the plant closes to Martin
and sort of defend itself against the
drought obviously you wilt more the
plant loses more water but at the same
time it's producing photosynthesis so
it's a trade-off between photosynthesis
and transpiration so yeah so the
threshold when the begins to decline
show the water conservation of the plant
so we started looking at all the number
of wild species and comparison
tetraploid species and we see the deep
Lloyds are much more conservative than a
tetraploid at a tendency we've done lots
of tests and you'll see that it deployed
to start closing stomata mature earlier
then there then the peanuts and then the
synthetics then we started looking at
one combination of two diploid and
deeper in their synthetic and what to
see that the parental deployed closes to
matter earlier than the synthetic
tetraploid so we realize that there is a
lot of changes in the plant once it's
set up realized that's one of the
changes so we cannot infer what the
plant what type of drought tolerance the
plot is going to have a quadrature they
deployed you have to go through the
whole process of tetraploid Isaac first
and then you assess the plants then you
look at what what they're like so this
is another one of them for other the
time surprise of these tetraploid II
and the other surprise was some deceit
so everything grows the leaves a bigger
the plant is bigger and it produces more
big lens it produces more you know this
and the other so and the focus of peanut
is the seed so great we duplicate the
plant and we're going to have bigger
seeds right wrong so that's one of our
sorrows out there you know why not why
can't we have the biggest seed and again
does not one cross one combination all
sorts of combinations we see the same
thing this is a diploid this is the
synthetic tetraploid this is the rock is
meticulous a undomesticated form of
peanut is one of the only tetraploid
species which are wild and these are
peanut peanuts different peanut
varieties of different seed size so we
see that's consistent the length the
width the way you know we don't see much
change so if we had some discussions
about it we haven't figured out why but
that's one of the things that we've
we've been finding well the good thing
about it is once you cross this plant
which is a tetraploid compatible with
peanut we get an F to population which
with a lot of segregation so it's not
all bad I know after a few rounds of
selection we find we can get recover you
know plans which are you know we have
good resistant and also have good seed
size even larger than the original
recurrent parent so it's not all bad we
will manage to overcome that quite quite
easily so we looked at over 30 traits
and we find consistent changes with your
ploy d
so what happens in genome structure now
once we look well the plan changes so
what happens in the genome so I'd like
to point out that after a lot of work
trying to find Marcus as far as I know
ten tetraploid maps have been created so
far the top ones are the ones our group
is involved with and these are later on
and all of them they follow the
assumption that peanut is a nulla
tetraploid with this symmetric
combination so all of these use this
classic a low tetraploid model in which
you have the a janome let's say and the
bed you know and the recombination
happens independently so we have
recombination the a side and
recombination the B side and what we
found well this is it's a work we've
done recently we we had data sets from
different maps and we found that some
mark has behaved not the way we expected
it to so it doesn't really follow the
day stomach model and we looked at these
marks and we thought these the market
they don't work very well they haven't
simplified very well or the DNA is not
working and a lot of it would just
ignore so a lot of what we do when we
don't have an explanation we just have
to ignore a move on otherwise we stay on
forever in the same problem so a lot of
the markers we just know pushed under
the carpet we just ignored this is one
example of of a step marker so if we are
we are evaluating the a side we expect
only three groups
and look at the side we expect just a a
SC or CC okay look at a side AC you see
a a AC or CC not more than that but
often we found some markers which some
I'm not supposed to be there why do you
have this group here and you can only
explain with this model so we probably I
having recombination between the a and
the B genomes and these we found
consistently once we sort of click that
was about two years ago about two years
ago actually we were in pack and I saw a
talk on potato and I thought hang on
it's something here that maybe we are
missing so we look back at all our data
micro satellite data slip date and also
expression analysis data and you know
we've found that these strange markers
they were grouping into similar
positions in the chromosomes the linkage
groups so what we find here the green
parts are areas where we have Tetris
sonic for a genome so we have a higher
dosage of the a and no Lee sonic for the
B and the red is d'etre sonic for B and
knowledge sonic for a so yeah we started
looking at this data and this is a cross
between a peanut variety and a synthetic
a litter ployed so we could easily
establish that you know these is a
segmental a lot i deployed
so we at the time of you know sequencing
the genome the of appliance and do the
names is if this was some April
combination a big problem is it a big
issue is a small issue how do we deal
with it how we're going to create what
are the new models we are going to use
with to have an answer that but what new
models we are going to use to start
mapping peanuts now how we're going to
how is that going to affect our breeding
programs how in effect a selection so
the first peanut genome which is all
extra peanut but is the peanut
progenitors have been recently sequenced
versions of it have been available since
2004 and is a multinational initiative
and because peanut is a lot a triploid
the two sub genomes are so similar we
decided as a group to sequence the two
progenitors Iraqis if Isis in Iraq is
the rain ances and that's as I said has
been deposited in peanut base is it's
been freely available for almost three
years now and it's being curated by the
group of safe cannon from Iowa State and
you know that's being a very good source
of information form for the hope in the
community so we decided you know now we
can start entry some of these questions
with a with a genome so we know that the
crosses that involve wild species have a
good degree of tetra sonic recombination
but how much of that actually happens or
affect peanuts genetics because once you
have wilds you may have one or more wild
things going on but how about peanut
itself so we did some short read alumina
sequence some skin sequencing from
several peanut genotypes then we mapped
those sequences because we're going to
have a mix of
a and B sub genome so we map them onto
the dura 97 applies to the molecules and
so we designed some plots some random
plots of these sequences so if we have
which is the expected model of a and B
in the same dosage will get a plot like
these because we have the normalized
density a and B equals 1 but if we have
something that deviates that deviates
from this model again the plots are
going to be different so if you have
four of be when a density goes higher
and the a goes lower so this is a very
simple plot that i'm going to show you
they the ones in real life now so with
sequins about for two genotypes i'm not
going to show this here going to show
one genotype and three linkage groups
these are linkage group one what we see
is most of it is one so we see along
with most of the linkage group you see
us the same dosage 4a and 4b there is
some small deletions or maybe gene
conversion something we we shouldn't
know what they are but you can see small
variation along the chromosome linkage
group for is a total different thing
these linkage group for is harbors lots
of rj's a lot of resistance genes it's
their highly collinear the a and the B
link chromosome for Zaha lakhani
collinear and we see here the end low
dosage for a then low dosage should be
then for a again so there has been a lot
of recombination going on there between
the children ohms
and we see a similar thing in linkage
group 5 so in we should see about 6
million base pairs of the Rossoneri
combination so we're starting to analyze
this data but we already see a lot of
very interesting information and also
they vary between different cultivars
since we are looking at different or
tank of varieties we start to see some
trends for the different varieties and
we also see some transport Arrakis
monticola which is the wild tetraploid
peanut so we are beginning to think that
this you know this shoe this issue is
quite large is larger than we expected
so but if you're happy or sad about it
but it's something completely unexpected
and quite interesting and again that's
something of a beginning to touch now
what are the effects of tetrapod ization
on gene expression again a few of you
here very familiar with the whole
concept or of differences in gene
expression when you have general merger
when you have deployed Isaiah tetek
realization etc but it's something that
we are just beginning to investigate and
we have a very very nice model for it
because we have the two progenitors of
peanut Iraqis appliance and ordinances
recently created new deployed hybrids so
we are able to look at the diploid
hybrid before you weren't able to
because we thought the diploid high
didn't mean anything we throw them away
obviously they're different plants
difficult plans to keep because you hey
don't produce seed so you have to keep
them very attractive lease and not often
are you able to do that so now with the
new know a bit more about it we look at
this plants and with a different light
we have new synthetic a lot i deployed
because before we thought they were
completely stable now we are not so sure
we have synthetic a lot i deployed 10th
generation so we can see roughly what
happened along
all these rounds of selfie we also have
a rugged meticulous with is the one
species of peanut of wild peanut which
is tetraploid and it's probably a
pharaoh species of Pharaoh relative of
peanut and it could be what can it look
like thousands of years ago and then we
have peanut so we have a very nice model
to work with so we did RNA seek of
leaves mapped on again or to the drone n
so then applying student molecules and
you know these plots that i'm going to
show what I made them on saturday so
it's completely out of the oven
completely new so with you're trying to
understand what's going on this is the
genome so linkage group one again one of
the peanut cultivars not much going on
here but if you can see the new deployed
hybrid completely dominance okay and
then what happens when the tetrapod eyes
and you have a very good a and B balance
so we may need to saturate this data bit
and you know do some more tweaking but
it's quite clear here that you know
something really dramatic is happening
between the stage of depolarization to
the cutter polarization these are 10th
generation these are different synthetic
to these of the same parentals but done
at different times and the 10th
generation we don't see much dominance
at all these Iraqis Mon ticular which is
a wild species of peanut and peanut so
you know we can have a look at
domestication something happened here
but not much so possibly they were very
unstable in the first generations and
then later on you know there's complete
balance of the two sub genomes have you
looked look at linkage group for in
which you have a lot of treacherous
ohmic recombination here the ends
again linkage group for the new deployed
hybrids again complete one more complete
but a very good be dominance again when
is catalyzed days a be balanced now look
at the 10th generation okay these
doesn't come here okay there's a direct
thing because this is from a different
cross but what you can see is this base
plundered we've had for ten ten
generations look very stable looks
completely the same as ten years ago
when you look at the linkage group for
you see complete a dominance won almost
complete a dominance but not quite so
but that's not because this is not you
know a gene expression thing is it this
genomic so we we had some work before
there that we looked at there's complete
little suamico combination here so this
is more genomic event and looking at
Iraq is meticulous you see at the ends
the same signature of Tetris ohmic
recombination we see in a raucous
monticola and we also saw the same very
similar signature in peanut so clearly
there's a very preliminary results but
we are beginning to unravel very
interesting factors here I mean we some
things that seem to be very stable along
thousands of years and you see a lot of
great instability in the first
generations so there's a lot more work
to be done but it's you know it's
something we are very excited about so
go through the sorrows and joys and
surprises the first sorrow is peanuts
and Alex tetraploid with very low
genetic diversity and very poor disease
resistance so we've been crying like my
son with his foot stuck in here on the
bench because we felt completely stuck
for a number of years but haven't should
go forward and and you know get along
with it so the Prickett part is peanut
peanut has a more complex genetics then
we expected before so it's quite prickly
as a surprise but again it's something
we can deal with and and we're having a
lot of success in improving disease
resistance with wild alleles now with
the new genome sequence we can you know
go much fasting is much much better much
nice to work with then previously so
that's what wants to show you and I want
to acknowledge the funders of this
research and and the group have been
working with this is my colleague
partner husband that we've been working
with for the last 15 years on this on
this research has been you know great
joy to work with David Bowie early these
are my is the quorum it is many more
people than these students postdocs but
this is the core group in Brazil and
like like should point to their vows
who's the one who's been collecting and
organizing the gym class banks and he's
a great asset to to have and this is the
wonderful group of being we have in the
pleasure to work with him the US and I'd
like to point out Scott Jackson who's
our host friend and again we've been
having great joy working with and thank
you very much
I'll ask you starters have you made any
auto temperance no we have not now we
have not to yeah whether you get some of
the same qualities and it costs those to
make you yes yeah there have been some
experts some crazy experiments we
thought about and we like making
octopodes all auto-generate so that's
there will be some things that we
thought of doing but because we are very
much interested in application and you
know all the crosses we make we are
looking at the science behind it but we
are always looking at if you can get
some product of the other line from them
I was at hand specifically about the
issue of the variability between deploys
and the tetraploid States copy the tetra
Floyd's first could you then assess cure
disease resistance or other qualities
and then right ok so duplicate the two
deploys and then crossing yes yeah I
could have yeah
today occasionally
are you fighting it though
when you find that there are really
infected
there
capture or you
many different
right great yes yeah well obviously
pro-thaksin is a some today's interest a
lot of people from different crops as
well our group we haven't done work
directly with aflatoxin ourselves what
we've done is we created some tetraploid
and in collaboration with senegal
they've been looking at they've been
done been doing field trials for
diseases and they've been assessing up a
toxin and i think what they're finding
is that some of these i think they are
bc they have they have segmental lines
they have some advanced lines a lot of
the lines are more more resistant than
the recurrent parent but they find their
face these small be additive effect and
they are they don't have anything of
major effect everything is additive and
of small effect to the organelle genomes
play any role
the success of the crosses
yeah he's something we haven't looked at
no we haven't looked at
yes
actually have a difference
they're universal yes yes yes it's a
phase is puzzling because it's I think
it involved independently in other two
taxane in legumes but they are not
necessarily related to two rockets at
all so vigna subterranea is one of them
and it's far away and all the Rockets
features have sought erroneous routes
yeah
but if you correct on
you know me
and spread them
yeah well that's a great question so
obviously what we are showing here were
two different things in 11 was the
genetic side of it the other way the
expression so we haven't corrected that
yet so that's that's one of the next
steps to do absolutely yeah
no no there isn't any ruckus species
that is haploid that we know so we've
been working and all these fishes that
are in the Iraqis section it will work
with across the bow are deployed this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu